Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日促销活动现已开启，您的夏天由此开始。是时候用特价仅需199美元的四头燃气烤炉来开启夏日烧烤了。整个季节，您还可以用仅需49美元的Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅招待亲友。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期至5月14日或5月27日。仅限美国，受条款限制。详情请访问HomeDepot.com/pricematch。
Each year, more than 50 million adults in the U.S. experience chronic pain. Whether it's caused by arthritis, injury, or something else, chronic pain can affect every aspect of a person's life and significantly limit their daily activities. Many people turn first to medications for pain, but in recent years, researchers and patients have found that behavioral approaches and therapies can play an important role in pain treatment and management. Today I'm going to talk to a pain psychologist about what effective treatments are available for chronic pain. We'll also discuss the link between chronic pain and mental health.
每年，美国有超过5000万成年人经历慢性疼痛。无论是由于关节炎、受伤还是其他原因引起，慢性疼痛都会影响一个人生活的方方面面，并严重限制其日常活动。许多人首先求助于药物来缓解疼痛，但近年来，研究人员和患者发现，行为疗法和心理治疗在疼痛的治疗和管理中可以发挥重要作用。今天，我将采访一位疼痛心理学家，探讨有哪些有效的慢性疼痛治疗方法。我们还将讨论慢性疼痛与心理健康之间的联系。
How does pain interact with anxiety, depression, and stress? How does emotion affect our experience of pain? What promising new pain treatments may be on the horizon? And if you're living with chronic pain, where can you go for help? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Rachel Aaron, an assistant professor of physical medicine and rehabilitation at the Johns Hopkins School of Medicine. She's a clinical psychologist who specializes in treating patients with chronic pain,
疼痛如何与焦虑、抑郁和压力相互作用？情绪如何影响我们的疼痛体验？未来有哪些有前景的新型疼痛疗法？如果您正饱受慢性疼痛的困扰，可以去哪里寻求帮助？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是约翰霍普金斯大学医学院物理医学与康复学助理教授瑞秋·亚伦（Dr. Rachel Aaron）博士。她是一位临床心理学家，专门治疗慢性疼痛、
illness, and injury. She also studies the psychosocial factors that contribute to chronic pain, especially the role of emotion in pain. She's authored more than 60 peer-reviewed journal articles on the experience and treatment of chronic pain in children and adults. Dr. Aaron, thank you for joining me today. Hi, Kim. Thank you so much for having me. It's really an honor to be here and to speak to such a large audience of people interested in psychology.
疾病和损伤患者。她还研究导致慢性疼痛的社会心理因素，特别是情绪在疼痛中的作用。她撰写了60多篇关于儿童和成人慢性疼痛体验与治疗的同行评审期刊文章。亚伦博士，感谢您今天接受我的采访。你好，金。非常感谢邀请我。能来到这里并向这么多对心理学感兴趣的听众发言，我深感荣幸。
Let's start with a basic question, which we often do, which is, how do you define chronic pain? So typically chronic pain is described as pain that has persisted for three months or longer past the point of expected healing. So, you know, acute pain is a part of life. Acute pain is adaptive. It tells us that something's wrong in our body. It tells us to seek help or to slow down if we're healing. But when that pain persists for more than three months after the body has healed from injury or acute pain, then we typically think of that as chronic. And is pain a physical experience, a mental experience, or both? What we know today is that pain is the sort of fancy term for this is bio-sico-social. So pain is a combination of biological experiences, psychological experiences, and social experiences.
让我们从一个基本问题开始，这也是我们经常问的：您如何定义慢性疼痛？通常，慢性疼痛被描述为持续三个月或更长时间，且超过了预期愈合时间的疼痛。急性疼痛是生活的一部分，它是适应性的。它告诉我们身体出了问题，提醒我们寻求帮助或在康复期间放慢节奏。但当这种疼痛在身体从损伤或急性疼痛中恢复后仍持续超过三个月时，我们通常将其视为慢性疼痛。那么，疼痛是一种生理体验、心理体验，还是两者兼有？我们今天所知道的是，疼痛有一个专业的术语叫“生物-心理-社会”模型。因此，疼痛是生物学体验、心理学体验和社会学体验的结合。
And that is true of all pain, whether it's acute or whether it's chronic. Our psychological state, our psychological experiences, the context in which the pain occurs, all affect the way that our brain processes and generates physical pain. What are the most common causes of chronic pain? Causes is an interesting question. It's easier to speak to common types of pain diagnoses or conditions, but actually about half the time we don't know what caused the chronic pain. So often chronic pain develops after an injury or after a surgery, sometimes after an illness,
所有疼痛都是如此，无论是急性的还是慢性的。我们的心理状态、心理体验以及疼痛发生的背景，都会影响大脑处理和产生生理疼痛的方式。慢性疼痛最常见的原因是什么？“原因”是一个有趣的问题。谈论常见的疼痛诊断或病症更容易，但实际上，大约有一半的时间我们不知道慢性疼痛的起因。通常，慢性疼痛是在受伤或手术后，有时是在患病后发展的，
or it's a symptom of some sort of illness or disease or condition. But in most cases, we actually can't pinpoint a specific cause of chronic pain. And, you know, speaking of the psychological experiences, that's a real source of distress for a lot of people to be experiencing very severe pain and not understand where that pain is coming from or why. What are the most common treatments for chronic pain and which are the most effective? Yeah, there's all sorts of treatments for chronic pain. there are, you know, and depending on the type of chronic pain, there are different types of medications that can be used. There are different types of medical interventions, things like
或者它是某种疾病或病症的症状。但在大多数情况下，我们实际上无法查明慢性疼痛的具体原因。而且，谈到心理体验，对于许多人来说，经历剧烈疼痛却不明白疼痛的来源或原因，这确实是一个巨大的痛苦来源。慢性疼痛最常见的治疗方法是什么？哪些最有效？是的，慢性疼痛的治疗方法多种多样。根据慢性疼痛的类型，可以使用不同类型的药物。还有各种医疗干预措施，比如
nerve blocks that can be used. People use all sorts of complementary treatments like yoga, massage, and acupuncture, things like this. You know, my area of expertise is in psychological interventions for pain. So, you know, we also, after several decades of research and anecdotes from clinical care now understand that psychological treatments are considered a frontline treatment for chronic pain. And what are those psychotherapeutic treatments for pain that are effective? I mean, if I come to you and I say, you know, my back is killing me and I've been treating it with drugs and I can't get around it, what can I possibly do psychologically that might help me deal with the pain and lessen it? So historically, the most extensively studied psychological treatment for chronic pain is called
神经阻滞等。人们也会使用各种补充疗法，如瑜伽、按摩和针灸等。我的专业领域是疼痛的心理干预。经过几十年的研究和临床护理经验，我们现在了解到，心理治疗被认为是慢性疼痛的一线治疗方法。那么，哪些有效的心理治疗方法可以用于疼痛呢？如果我来找您，说我的背痛得要命，我一直在用药治疗，但还是无法缓解，我在心理上能做些什么来帮助我应对并减轻疼痛呢？从历史上看，研究最广泛的慢性疼痛心理治疗被称为
cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT, which I'm sure this audience is quite familiar with. And fortunately, seems to be a sort of a household word these days, CBT. You know, CBT was developed to treat depression and anxiety, and it's been adapted to help people cope with chronic pain. So the goal of cognitive behavioral therapy for chronic pain is to help people examine the types of thoughts that they have about pain. Thoughts like my pain will never go away or my life is over or I can never be the mother, father, spouse, friend, professional that I was when I live with this pain. So a core piece of CBT is helping people identify those thoughts and work with them to be a little bit more neutral or realistic. That's sort of the C of CBT. The B or the behavioral part is helping people be
认知行为疗法（CBT），我相信我们的听众对此非常熟悉。幸运的是，CBT如今似乎已经成为家喻户晓的词汇。CBT最初是为治疗抑郁症和焦虑症而开发的，后来被改编用于帮助人们应对慢性疼痛。因此，针对慢性疼痛的认知行为疗法的目标是帮助人们审视他们对疼痛的想法。比如“我的疼痛永远不会消失”、“我的生活完了”或者“我无法再像以前那样成为母亲、父亲、配偶、朋友或专业人士”。CBT的核心部分是帮助人们识别这些想法，并调整它们，使其变得更加中立或现实。这是CBT中“C”（认知）的部分。而“B”（行为）的部分是帮助人们
active despite pain. So working together a patient and the clinician to set very specific goals around activity, physical activities or pleasant activities, helping people pace their activity to avoid overdoing or underdoing activity. So these are some of the core components of CBT. And again, And that's sort of been the most extensively studied. There are several related treatments. There is a group of treatments that take a mindfulness-based approach to pain. And there are treatments that take something called an acceptance and commitment therapy act. Again, this audience is familiar.
尽管有疼痛也要保持活跃。患者与临床医生共同设定关于身体活动或愉悦活动的具体目标，帮助人们调整活动节奏，避免过度或活动不足。这些是CBT的核心组成部分。此外，还有一些相关的治疗方法。有一组治疗方法采用基于正念的方法来处理疼痛。还有一种被称为接纳承诺疗法（ACT）的治疗方法。同样，我们的听众对此也很熟悉。
So helping people learn to live a valued life despite pain, learn to accept the experience of pain. And then there's also a new class of psychological treatments that have come about in recent years that focus more on the affective or emotional components of pain. It sounds like these are all treatments that are helping you manage and live with the pain, but not alleviating the pain. So what are the most effective treatments for alleviating pain? Great question. So CBT and CBT-based treatments came around at a time when we thought of chronic pain as a chronic condition that could not necessarily be altered in the same way that you might think of other types of physical disabilities.
即帮助人们学会尽管有疼痛也要过上有价值的生活，学会接纳疼痛的体验。此外，近年来出现了一类新的心理治疗方法，它们更多地关注疼痛的情感或情绪成分。听起来这些治疗方法都是在帮助管理和带痛生活，而不是消除疼痛。那么，消除疼痛最有效的治疗方法是什么？这是一个很好的问题。CBT和基于CBT的治疗方法出现时，我们认为慢性疼痛是一种慢性疾病，不一定能像其他类型的身体残疾那样被改变。
And CBT was developed to help people cope with that pain. So the sort of initial framework of CBT was, you know what, you've seen all these doctors and you've had all these evaluations. And you know what? It looks like your pain's not going to go away. So let's figure out how you can cope with it better. Let's figure out how it can cause you less distress. And let's figure out how you can be more physically active.
因此，CBT的最初框架是：你已经看过所有医生，做过所有评估，看起来你的疼痛不会消失。所以，让我们找出如何更好地应对它。让我们找出如何让它减少对你的困扰。让我们找出如何让你在身体上更活跃。
So CBT and related treatments really came out of this idea that we were helping people manage pain. And the goal of those treatments is actually not necessarily pain reduction. And in fact, in the early days, the idea was sort of that you might sort of coach someone on. This pain might never change. Like your pain might never go away. We need to help you accept that. So there's been a lot of research in recent years to understand the neuroscience of chronic pain. and what we're learning is that pain is not always chronic for all people.
所以CBT及相关疗法确实源于这种帮助人们管理疼痛的理念。这些治疗的目标实际上并不一定是减轻疼痛。事实上，在早期，这种理念更像是指导某人：这种疼痛可能永远不会改变，你的疼痛可能永远不会消失，我们需要帮助你接受这一点。近年来，关于慢性疼痛神经科学的研究有很多，我们了解到，疼痛对所有人来说并不总是慢性的。
There are many instances where chronic pain can be reversed. And so we've seen a huge shift in treatment, in psychological treatment, towards how can we actually help people's pain get better? Now that we know what we know about the neuroscience of pain, and we know that there are some psychological factors that might lead to or maintain pain, how can we actually help pain go away. And that's where that class of more emotion-focused interventions come in. So one thing that is really unique about these particular treatments, one example is emotional
在许多情况下，慢性疼痛是可以逆转的。因此，我们在治疗，特别是在心理治疗方面看到了巨大的转变，即我们如何才能真正帮助人们减轻疼痛？既然我们了解了疼痛的神经科学，并且知道有一些心理因素可能导致或维持疼痛，我们如何才能真正帮助疼痛消失？这就是那些更关注情绪的干预措施发挥作用的地方。这些特定治疗方法的一个独特之处在于，例如情绪
awareness and expression therapy, which was developed by Mark Lumley, who is a psychologist at Wayne State University, who had sort of over the course of decades built up towards this amazing intervention. And it has gone a bit of a radical direction in terms of how we treat pain. And one thing that it's done that's very different is it a true. It addresses trauma. It addresses historical experiences of life trauma, adverse life events, even experiences of discrimination or stigma. So whereas some of the CBT and the CBT-based treatments kind of came in saying, well, let's talk about what's going on in your life now, the past isn't important because we want to kind of stay symptom focused and focused on the here
意识与表达疗法（EAET），它是由韦恩州立大学的心理学家马克·伦利（Mark Lumley）开发的，他在几十年的时间里构建了这种出色的干预措施。它在治疗疼痛方面走了一个相当激进的方向。它与众不同的一点是，它处理创伤。它处理生活中的历史创伤、不良生活事件，甚至是歧视或污名化的经历。因此，虽然一些CBT和基于CBT的治疗方法倾向于说“让我们谈谈你现在生活中发生了什么，过去并不重要，因为我们想专注于症状和当下”，
and now. You know, EAET pulled in some more of those historical themes around let's actually talk about your childhood and talk about difficult things that happened to you. And by the way, connect that to pain. So you sort of help people understand the link between stress or trauma and pain. And that treatment is resulting in improved pain for people with particular types of pain conditions. So, you know, it's a great question that signals actually this shift in the psychology of pain treatment. You've studied the link between pain and anxiety and depression. What have you found? How are these three situations related to each other? What we know is that people who have chronic pain are more likely than people in the average population or in the general public to have depression and anxiety.
但EAET引入了更多关于历史的主题，比如“让我们谈谈你的童年，谈谈发生在你身上的困难事情”，并将其与疼痛联系起来。因此，你帮助人们理解压力或创伤与疼痛之间的联系。这种治疗正在改善特定类型疼痛患者的状况。所以，这是一个很好的问题，它实际上标志着疼痛心理治疗的转变。您研究过疼痛与焦虑、抑郁之间的联系。您发现了什么？这三种情况是如何相互关联的？我们知道，患有慢性疼痛的人比普通人群更容易患上抑郁症和焦虑症。
So my colleagues and I actually just completed a systematic review of the last 10 years of research studies measuring depression and anxiety and chronic pain. So we identified hundreds of studies, hundreds of thousands of participants. And we found that number to be a around 40%. So around 40% of people who have chronic pain also have depression or have anxiety. So, you know, we know that rates are high. So we know that this co-occurrence is common. The co-occurrence of pain and depression or pain and anxiety is common. But some other things we now know or not everybody has these co-occurring conditions, right? Many people live really high functioning lives with chronic pain and it doesn't affect their mood. But for a lot of people with pain, depression is high. And we're still trying to figure out how to treat that particular
我和我的同事刚刚完成了一项系统综述，回顾了过去10年测量抑郁、焦虑和慢性疼痛的研究。我们确定了数百项研究，涉及数十万名参与者。我们发现这个比例大约是40%。也就是说，大约40%的慢性疼痛患者同时患有抑郁症或焦虑症。我们知道发病率很高，这种共病现象很常见。但我们现在还知道其他一些事情，并不是每个人都有这些共病，对吧？许多人带着慢性疼痛依然过着高质量的生活，这并没有影响他们的情绪。但对于许多疼痛患者来说，抑郁程度很高。我们仍在努力寻找治疗这种特定
comorbidity. But I can tell you more about what we don't know. So we know that the prevalence is high. What we don't know are how pain and depression or anxiety develop over time. So sort of the old way of thinking, many decades ago before the surge of research and before the surge of understanding the neuroscience of pain was, well, if you have chronic pain, you must be depressed because having chronic pain is depressing. That's a very ableist narrative, by the way, to assume that someone with a chronic condition must be depressed, right? So, you know, we used to think that sort of pain led to depression or anxiety. But what the literature, there's not too much, there haven't been too many studies really trying to parse this relationship. But what we can see
共病的方法。但我可以告诉你更多我们尚不了解的内容。我们知道患病率很高，但我们不知道疼痛与抑郁或焦虑是如何随时间发展的。几十年前，在研究激增和对疼痛神经科学的理解加深之前，旧的思维方式是：如果你有慢性疼痛，你一定会抑郁，因为患有慢性疼痛令人沮丧。顺便说一句，假设患有慢性疾病的人一定很抑郁，这是一种非常歧视残疾人的叙事。所以，我们过去认为疼痛导致了抑郁或焦虑。但现有的文献显示，虽然没有太多研究真正试图解析这种关系，但我们可以看到
from the studies that we do have is that those relationships are bidirectional. So sometimes chronic pain precedes depression and anxiety, and sometimes depression and anxiety, precedes chronic pain. And I think that where we will go next is understanding how that might be different for different types of chronic pain conditions. So one of the reasons I became interested in this topic was I myself was experiencing chronic pain. And you just talked about the link between depression and pain. Now, I was not depressed, but one of the treatments that was prescribed for me was an antidepressant, duloxatine was given to me. And I have to say it didn't do anything for me. I wasn't depressed, so I didn't feel happier, but it did nothing for my pain. So what is
从我们现有的研究中发现，这些关系是双向的。有时慢性疼痛先于抑郁和焦虑，有时抑郁和焦虑先于慢性疼痛。我认为我们接下来的方向是了解这对于不同类型的慢性疼痛病症有何不同。我之所以对这个话题感兴趣，是因为我自己也曾经历过慢性疼痛。您刚才谈到了抑郁和疼痛之间的联系。我当时并不抑郁，但医生给我开的一种治疗药物是抗抑郁药——度洛西汀。我必须说，它对我没有任何作用。我不抑郁，所以没有感到更快乐，但它对我的疼痛也毫无帮助。那么
going on with these antidepressants and pain? How are they changing people's experience of pain? Yeah. Thank you for sharing that. And I'm sorry to hear that you were sort of prescribed something that came with plenty of side effects and wasn't helpful to you in the end. And so in general, we don't know a lot about sort of the best course of treatment. So we sort of have these treatments as a laundry list of treatments, but we're not as the science is not at a state that we know that this particular treatment works best for this particular pain condition and this particular type of person. So, you know, it's a bit like throwing a dart on a dart on a dart board. You know, you kind of try what you can. So antidepressant medications are considered a frontline treatment
这些抗抑郁药和疼痛之间到底是怎么回事？它们是如何改变人们的疼痛体验的？是的，感谢您的分享。很遗憾听到您被开了某种药物，它带来了很多副作用，最终对您也没有帮助。总的来说，我们对最佳治疗方案了解不多。我们有一份治疗方法的清单，但科学还没有达到我们知道某种特定治疗方法对某种特定疼痛病症和某种特定类型的人最有效的程度。所以，这有点像在飞镖盘上投飞镖。你只能尝试你能尝试的方法。抗抑郁药物被认为是
for some types of chronic pain conditions. And the idea is that antidepressants, you know, acknowledging I'm not a physician, but the idea is that. that antidepressants can operate on different sorts of channels that could reduce inflammation, that could reduce sort of the central sensitization of pain in the body. So it could sort of slow down those pain signals or turn them down a little bit. They work for some people, but not for everybody. And we don't know why. Interesting. And we tried a bunch of things. I'm going to ask you about another couple of therapies that I went through. So I went to acupuncture for a while. And I've had acupuncture for other pain that has been transient and it's been very effective. For this particular
某些类型慢性疼痛的一线治疗方法。其理念是——声明我不是医生——抗抑郁药可以在不同的通道上发挥作用，从而减少炎症，减少身体中疼痛的中心敏化。因此，它可以减缓那些疼痛信号，或者稍微调低它们。它们对有些人有效，但不是对每个人都有效。我们不知道原因。有趣。我们尝试了很多方法。我想问您关于我经历过的另外几种疗法。我做过一段时间针灸。我曾因其他短暂的疼痛做过针灸，效果非常好。但对于这种特定的
pain, didn't do a thing. How effective is acupuncture in treating chronic pain? The evidence is quite mixed and partly that's because there haven't been a ton of high quality research studies in this area. But I think overall we could say minimally effective, but important caveat compared to active control. So if you give one group of people acupuncture and you give one group of people nothing, people who get acupuncture will feel better than the people who got nothing. If you compare sort of real acupuncture to like sham acupuncture, so you sort of hook some needles, but not necessarily, you know, the way that acupuncture is supposed to be delivered,
疼痛，它一点用都没有。针灸在治疗慢性疼痛方面有多有效？证据非常混杂，部分原因是该领域缺乏大量高质量的研究。但我认为总的来说，我们可以说它是微弱有效的，但有一个重要的前提：与主动对照组相比。如果你给一组人做针灸，给另一组人什么都不做，做针灸的人会感觉比什么都不做的人好。如果你将真正的针灸与“假针灸”进行比较，即扎一些针，但不一定按照针灸应有的方式进行，
we don't see huge treatment effects. And again, there's a lot of treatments out there. A placebo control is powerful. Expectations matter a whole lot, you know? And so if someone came to me in my pain clinic, and said, I really want to try acupuncture, I think that could really help me. Then I would say, absolutely, go for it. If you think something's going to help you and you believe something's going to help you, then it probably will. Yeah, because it had worked before. I thought it was going
我们看不到巨大的治疗效果。同样，市面上有太多的治疗方法。安慰剂对照很强大。期望值非常重要。所以，如果有人来到我的疼痛诊所说：“我真的很想尝试针灸，我认为这对我真的有帮助。”那么我会说：“绝对可以，去试试吧。”如果你认为某件事会有帮助，并且你相信它会有帮助，那么它很可能就会有帮助。是的，因为之前有效过，我以为这次也会
to do it, but it didn't in this case. So then we stopped doing that. And the acupuncturist suggested that I try red light therapy. Now, is that totally woo-woo or does that really work? I think we could probably put that on a list of a lot of things that maybe totally woo-woo certainly haven't been subjected to like randomized control trials. But I think that because we don't know exactly how to treat chronic pain and because in most cases we don't know exactly where that chronic pain came from when people are living with chronic pain or treating people with chronic pain are interested in this topic, it's just sort of easy to sort of like cast a wide net and think, well, maybe this will help me or maybe this will out me. And I'll say that that is also fueled by the biomedical model of pain. So we talked about the biopsychosocial model of pain. That replaced the biomedical model of pain, which is the idea that, you know, pain is a, the experience of pain is perfectly correlated with some degree of injury or pathology in the body. So the idea that we should just be able to identify the source of the pain and identify the best treatment for that pain is very rooted in that biomedical model, which unfortunately, as of yet,
有效，但这次没有。所以我们停止了。针灸师建议我尝试红光疗法。这完全是伪科学，还是真的有效？我想我们大概可以把它列入很多可能完全是伪科学的清单中，它们肯定没有经过像随机对照试验那样的验证。但我认为，因为我们不知道如何准确治疗慢性疼痛，而且在大多数情况下，我们不知道慢性疼痛的来源，所以当人们患有慢性疼痛或治疗慢性疼痛的人对这个话题感兴趣时，很容易撒网，认为“也许这会有帮助”。我要说的是，这也受到疼痛生物医学模型的推动。我们谈到了疼痛的生物-心理-社会模型。它取代了疼痛的生物医学模型，即认为疼痛体验与身体损伤或病理程度完全相关。因此，我们应该能够识别疼痛来源并确定最佳治疗方法的想法，深深植根于生物医学模型中，不幸的是，到目前为止，
is not helping us explain pain. And that's why those psychological pieces are so important for so many people. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay.
它并没有帮助我们解释疼痛。这就是为什么心理因素对许多人如此重要的原因。现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。即使蜂巢嗡嗡作响，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需35美元。这可是个稍纵即逝的优惠。
Explore GoogleFi wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Well, we were definitely throwing darts at this for a while. I have to say, and so for our listeners, any of you who are experiencing this, yeah, you may go through a lot of different treatments, you know, before you find something that works, which I finally did. It was actually an epidural, and it has helped a lot. But cortisone injections, right, are a fairly common treatment for pain and can be effective as I have learned.
立即探索Google Fi Wireless套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。在网络高负荷时段，无线服务不受数据流量降速限制。好吧，我们确实尝试了各种方法。我必须说，对于我们的听众，任何正在经历这种情况的人，是的，在找到有效的方法之前，你可能会经历很多不同的治疗，我最终找到了。实际上是硬膜外注射，它帮助很大。但可的松注射确实是相当常见的疼痛治疗方法，正如我所了解的那样，它们可能是有效的。
I want to ask you, though, about how you create a pain plan. I mean, because I think, as I said, we were throwing darts at things. If somebody were to come into your clinic and say, you know, this is, I've been having pain for the last two years and I really can't deal with this anymore, how do you set them up to determine what is the best course of treatment? Yeah, so I'll address that, but I want to back up a little and talk about throwing the darts at the dark board. And I just want to say for people who are listening who might have personal experience,
不过，我想问您关于如何制定疼痛计划的问题。因为正如我所说，我们是在盲目尝试。如果有人走进您的诊所说：“我过去两年一直有疼痛，我真的无法再忍受了。”您如何引导他们确定最佳的治疗方案？是的，我会回答这个问题，但我想退后一步，谈谈“盲目尝试”的问题。我想对正在收听并可能有个人经历的人说，
So that is some degree of seeking treatment for chronic pain is throwing dars at dartboard. That is sort of an inherent part of it. I think that there are some potential pitfalls for people to be aware of. And I think the biggest one is just how collaborative you feel with your providers. Because sometimes providers get frustrated when they're not throwing the right dart at the right place on the dart. And that's where we get, again, some of that abelism or some of that bias saying, well, this must be a you problem. Right. We've tried 10 different biomedical things and nothing's working.
寻求慢性疼痛治疗在某种程度上确实是在盲目尝试。这是其内在的一部分。我认为人们需要意识到一些潜在的陷阱。我认为最大的一点是你与医疗提供者之间的协作感。因为有时当提供者没有在正确的地方投中飞镖时，他们会感到沮丧。这就是我们再次遇到那种残疾歧视或偏见的地方，他们会说：“这一定是你的问题。”对吧？我们尝试了10种不同的生物医学方法，但都没有用。
So this must be a U problem. So I would say if you're in that reaction is unfortunately quite common. You know, it used to be I only saw people in my chronic pain psychology clinic because of that reason, because of a sort of a physician saying, well, this is a U problem. So go see a psychologist. You know, this has changed so much in recent years with greater adoption of the biopsychosocial model. And now people are incorporating mental health perspectives from sort of the beginning.
所以这一定是你的问题。所以我想说，如果你处于那种反应中，不幸的是，这种情况很常见。你知道，我过去只在我的慢性疼痛心理诊所里见到因为这个原因而来的人，因为医生说：“这是你的问题，所以去看心理医生吧。”近年来，随着生物-心理-社会模型的广泛采用，这种情况已经发生了很大变化。现在人们从一开始就纳入了心理健康视角。
But I just want to kind of highlight that that throwing darts in a dartboard is part of the process. And it's important that you feel collaborative with your provider and you feel like you have their respect and that they, you know, view your pain is valid. Which fortunately, it seems like you had supportive providers in your case. Yeah, I mean, I was willing to try what they suggested. And when that didn't work, okay, let's go to plan C. Let's go to plan F. You know, we just kept working our way through. So in terms of what I do, you know, one of the most important things is just understanding what the person's goal is.
但我只是想强调，盲目尝试是过程的一部分。重要的是你与提供者之间感到协作，你觉得你得到了他们的尊重，并且他们认为你的疼痛是真实的。幸运的是，在您的案例中，您似乎有支持您的提供者。是的，我愿意尝试他们建议的方法。当那个方法无效时，好吧，让我们进入C计划，进入F计划。我们只是不断地尝试。所以就我所做的而言，最重要的事情之一就是了解个人的目标是什么。
And, you know, so sometimes people have very specific goals around return to work or engagement in physical activity or just finding more joy in their life. So knowing exactly what their goal is is always going to be an important part of that treatment design. Well, I'll always get a detailed history, including understanding what sort of traumatic experiences someone might have had or experience in their life. And, you know, that's also used to inform what kind of treatment we go through together. We do a lot of different types of start off treatment with some questionnaires to understand, you know, what is depression like? What is anxiety like? Are these symptoms that we're also going to be addressing in treatment? And then to get at that CBT model, we ask some questions about.
有时人们有关于重返工作岗位、参与体育活动或仅仅在生活中寻找更多快乐的具体目标。因此，明确他们的目标始终是治疗设计的重要组成部分。我会详细了解病史，包括了解某人生活中可能经历过的创伤经历。这也被用来告知我们一起进行什么样的治疗。我们从一些问卷开始治疗，以了解抑郁症是什么样的？焦虑症是什么样的？这些是我们将在治疗中解决的症状吗？然后为了实现CBT模型，我们询问一些关于
thoughts around pain ability to, you know, physical function, things like that. So all of that type of information is going to be useful. So sort of someone's symptom profile, their history, and their treatment goals. What role, if any, does hypnosis play in pain management? Hypnosis for pain is another evidence-based approach to pain. So there have been numerous clinical trials that have shown that hypnosis can have a small effect on pain. I'll say this is not as widely practiced as some of the other treatments. It requires really specialized training that not everyone has. You know, I think the goal of hypnosis, one important thing to state would be people learn to sort of apply these practices to themselves. So it's almost like there's a lot of similarities with
对疼痛能力的看法、身体功能等问题。所以所有这些信息都是有用的。即某人的症状概况、病史和治疗目标。催眠在疼痛管理中起什么作用（如果有的话）？催眠治疗疼痛是另一种基于证据的疼痛方法。已经有许多临床试验表明催眠对疼痛有轻微的影响。我要说的是，这不像其他治疗方法那样被广泛实践。它需要非常专业的培训，并不是每个人都有。我认为催眠的目标，重要的一点是人们学会将这些练习应用到自己身上。所以它几乎与
mindfulness meditation. So, you know, sometimes people think like standing on a stage and clucking like a chicken. So there's a lot of stereotypes about what that is. But Indeed, that is a respected and evidence-based treatment or chronic pain. You know, another treatment that's out there that seems to be applied to almost anything you can think of today is psychedelics. And I'm just wondering where we are with the use of all kinds of psychedelics and chronic pain and not even psychedelics, even things like marijuana, you know, CBD. The evidence for cannabis-based products is very mixed. and very political. It's subject to a lot of sort of hot debate in field
正念冥想有很多相似之处。有时人们认为催眠就是站在舞台上像鸡一样咯咯叫。所以关于它是什么有很多刻板印象。但事实上，这是一种受人尊敬且基于证据的慢性疼痛治疗方法。你知道，另一种似乎今天被应用于你能想到的几乎任何事情的治疗方法是迷幻药。我只是想知道我们在使用各种迷幻药治疗慢性疼痛方面处于什么位置，甚至不是迷幻药，而是像大麻、CBD之类的东西。基于大麻的产品证据非常混杂，
and people having sort of all sorts of different vested interests in what outcome comes out. I will say that right now, like acupuncture, we don't see cannabis-based treatments having big effects when they're compared to a good control condition. But I will again say that expectations matter so much, you know, what people think or believe is going to help them. And, you know, with that comes a sense of control, right?
而且非常政治化。它在领域内受到很多激烈的辩论，人们对结果有各种不同的既得利益。我要说的是，目前像针灸一样，当与良好的对照条件进行比较时，我们没有看到基于大麻的治疗方法有显著效果。但我还是要说，期望值非常重要，人们认为或相信什么会有帮助。随之而来的是一种控制感，对吧？
Oh, here's something I can do. Here's something I can try. I feel like this pain is totally out of my hands. So here's something, you know. And certainly that's important to have something that you feel like you have some control over. And if someone feels like something works for them, then, you know, in most cases, I'm not going to dissuade them from that. In terms of psychedelics, that's a very new area of research.
“哦，这是我可以做的事情。这是我可以尝试的事情。”我觉得这种疼痛完全超出了我的控制。所以这里有一些你觉得可以控制的事情。当然，拥有一些你觉得可以控制的事情很重要。如果有人觉得某件事对他们有效，那么在大多数情况下，我不会劝阻他们。至于迷幻药，这是一个非常新的研究领域。
There are a number of ongoing studies right now. And I don't know that the results are actually. out there yet. They're still ongoing sort of recruiting participants. So, you know, TBD. Let's talk for a moment about emotion regulation and pain management, because I know that's an area where you've done some work. What does that mean? I mean, how do you apply emotion regulation to managing your pain? You know, emotion regulation refers to one's ability to sort of change or alter their emotional state in a more desired direction. So living with pain can be very distressing, experiencing pain can feel very distressed.
目前有许多正在进行的研究。我不知道结果是否已经公布。它们仍在进行中，正在招募参与者。所以，敬请期待。让我们谈谈情绪调节和疼痛管理，因为我知道这是您做过一些工作的地方。那是什么意思？您如何应用情绪调节来管理疼痛？情绪调节是指一个人以更理想的方向改变或调整其情绪状态的能力。因此，带痛生活可能会非常痛苦，经历疼痛会让人感到非常痛苦。
saying. And so the extent that someone is able to sort of manage the distress that comes up around that is going to affect how they're able to live with pain. So someone who is very skilled at feeling like their life, you know, some of these, these thoughts that I called out earlier, these like very negative thoughts about pain like my life is over or I can't be the mother that I want to be to my children. So people differ in how well they're able to sort of take that thought and do something about it. So we see that people who should, struggle to sort of manage that distress, have poor outcomes, they have worse pain over time. And just as important as sort of like feeling better when you feel bad is also just the ability
所以，一个人在多大程度上能够管理围绕疼痛产生的痛苦，将影响他们如何带痛生活。因此，一个非常擅长处理这些想法的人——我之前提到的那些关于疼痛的非常负面的想法，比如“我的生活完了”或“我无法成为我想成为的孩子们的母亲”——人们在处理这些想法的能力上有所不同。我们看到，那些难以管理这种痛苦的人，结果更差，随着时间的推移，他们的疼痛更严重。而且，在感觉糟糕时感觉好一点，与
to experience and express emotion. So sometimes people might not be as tuned into their emotional experiences or they might be really trying to tamp something down, like really don't want to talk about that. And so when people have a real tendency to sort of push that down and to avoid that emotion, avoid talking about that emotion, that can also lead to poor outcomes. That's where some of those emotion-focused treatments come in, are really trying to help people like dial up those feelings and express those feelings and learn and heal from those feelings. And you've also looked at chronic pain in children and adolescents. Can you talk about what your research found in? Does treating chronic pain in kids differ
体验和表达情绪的能力同样重要。有时人们可能不太关注自己的情绪体验，或者他们可能真的试图压抑某些东西，比如真的不想谈论那个。因此，当人们有真正压抑这种情绪并避免谈论这种情绪的倾向时，这也可能导致不良结果。这就是那些以情绪为中心的治疗方法发挥作用的地方，它们真正试图帮助人们调动这些感受，表达这些感受，并从中学习和治愈。您还研究过儿童和青少年的慢性疼痛。您能谈谈您的研究发现了什么吗？治疗儿童的慢性疼痛与治疗成人的慢性疼痛有何不同？
from the way that you treat chronic pain in adults? You know, it's been a while since I've done too much with pediatric populations. In terms of psychological interventions, the treatments are similar. That new category of emotion-focused treatments that I can't stop talking about have not yet been tested in kids. And I think that there are some real questions about how to do that safely and ethically. You know, with adults, you might talk about trauma from childhood that is in the past, you know, or you might talk about ongoing stressors that that adult.
距离我做太多儿科人群的研究已经有一段时间了。在心理干预方面，治疗方法是相似的。我一直在谈论的那种以情绪为中心的新型治疗方法尚未在儿童身上进行测试。我认为关于如何安全且合乎道德地做到这一点，确实存在一些真正的问题。对于成年人，你可能会谈论过去童年的创伤，或者你可能会谈论该成年人
has some control over. So I'm not exactly sure how that applies to pediatric populations. I think taking themes from that treatment is so important, but it hasn't been done yet. So I'm curious to see what that looks like. But otherwise, you know, CBT, like an adult is the most well-studied treatment for children and adolescents. One real advantage of treating pain, well, there are several advantages of treating pain in children and adolescents.
有一定控制权的持续压力源。所以我不太确定这如何应用于儿科人群。我认为从那种治疗中汲取主题非常重要，但目前还没有这样做。所以我很好奇那会是什么样子。但除此之外，CBT像成人一样，是儿童和青少年研究最充分的治疗方法。治疗儿童和青少年疼痛的一个真正优势，或者说有几个优势。
One is you can often get their environment, people in their environment involved. so you can get their parents or caregivers involved. You can even get the school involved. You know, so you can make some real changes to their environment that you can't really make with adults. Like people have done research studies incorporating the spouses of people with chronic pain. And, you know, they've kind of tried to get a social environment in that way. But, you know, it's really great to kind of have those other people involved, sort of change. You can talk to caregivers about the way that they're talking about pain.
一个是你可以经常让他们的环境、环境中的人参与进来。所以你可以让他们的父母或照顾者参与进来。你甚至可以让学校参与进来。所以你可以对他们的环境做出一些真正的改变，而这些改变在成人身上是无法真正做到的。人们已经进行了研究，将慢性疼痛患者的配偶纳入其中。他们试图以这种方式获得社会环境。但是，让其他人参与进来，做出改变，这真的很棒。你可以与照顾者谈论他们谈论疼痛的方式。
And so you can kind of make some good behavioral changes in that way. The other thing is that kids are more likely to get better. And that is, you know, there's a lot of reasons why that might be, but one is probably that that chronic pain isn't as instantiated, that their brains are still more malleable and that they might be more likely to get pain relief from treatment for that reason compared to, say, an adult that's had a chronic pain condition for decades. It's going to be a lot different. it's going to be a lot harder to sort of change the way to the brains responding to that pain or generating that pain.
所以你可以以这种方式做出一些好的行为改变。另一件事是孩子们更有可能好转。这有很多原因，但其中之一可能是慢性疼痛还没有那么根深蒂固，他们的大脑仍然更具可塑性，因此他们可能更有可能通过治疗获得疼痛缓解，相比之下，一个患有慢性疼痛几十年的成年人，情况会大不相同，
Let me ask you this for our listeners in particular. How do you know when you need some professional help to manage your chronic pain? And if you decide that you need help, where do you start? Most people who have chronic pain are doing just fine. You know, they're functioning in the world. They're achieving their goals. They're not depressed or anxious. they're doing okay and that's great and that should be reinforced.
改变大脑对疼痛的反应或产生疼痛的方式会困难得多。让我问您一个特别针对我们听众的问题。您怎么知道什么时候需要专业帮助来管理慢性疼痛？如果您决定需要帮助，从哪里开始？大多数患有慢性疼痛的人都做得很好。他们在世界上运作，他们正在实现他们的目标。他们没有抑郁或焦虑，他们做得很好，这很好，应该得到加强。
Like that's resilience and that's wonderful. So not everyone with chronic pain needs specialized mental health care treatment. You know, most people with chronic pain are doing okay. I think that reasons why you might seek treatment are if you start to have some of those really negative beliefs or thoughts about pain. So you're really starting, it's really getting you down. You're really starting to feel like you can't live in this world with the pain that you have or you can't be the person that you want to be and this is stressing or these thoughts are
这就是韧性，这很棒。所以并不是每个慢性疼痛患者都需要专门的心理健康护理治疗。大多数慢性疼痛患者都做得很好。我认为您可能寻求治疗的原因是，如果您开始产生一些关于疼痛的非常负面的信念或想法。所以它真的开始让你感到沮丧。你真的开始觉得你无法带着你所拥有的疼痛生活在这个世界上，或者你无法成为你想成为的人，而这种压力或这些想法是
frequent or common or hard to turn off. You know, these are all reasons why getting some help to deal with that might be helpful for people who have had maybe significant traumas or stressful events in their life that they haven't had the chance to fully heal from or process in the context of a therapeutic relationship or just with the passing of time. That might also be a reason to seek out therapy because those experiences can link to chronic pain. So finding someone that can help you sort of understand that link. So not just sort of resolving the trauma, but how might that link to pain that you're having today?
频繁的、常见的或难以停止的。这些都是寻求帮助的原因，对于那些在生活中可能经历过重大创伤或压力事件，但没有机会在治疗关系中或随着时间的推移完全治愈或处理的人来说，这可能也是寻求治疗的原因。因为这些经历可以与慢性疼痛联系起来。所以找到一个能帮助你理解这种联系的人。所以不仅仅是解决创伤，而是它如何与你今天所经历的疼痛联系起来？
Otherwise, I think if you have physical goals or life goals that you're not able to achieve, and that is a source of distress, then you might want to work with someone to figure out either, you know, how can I achieve these goals or how can I adapt this goal to the way that my body is functioning now? So those are some reasons why someone might seek treatment. Those might be some flags. And there are not a lot of mental health care providers who are specialized in chronic pain.
否则，我认为如果您有无法实现的身体目标或生活目标，并且这成为了困扰的来源，那么您可能需要与专业人士合作，找出如何实现这些目标，或者如何根据身体目前的机能状况来调整这些目标。这些就是人们寻求治疗的一些原因，也可能是需要警惕的信号。目前，专门从事慢性疼痛治疗的心理健康服务提供者并不多。
There are very few graduate pipelines for this area of specialty training. And so, you know, hopefully that's changing and shifting as there is more attention to this biopsychosocial model of pain. But it doesn't change the fact that today there are sort of a dearth of providers. So, you know, most providers are. found in academic medical centers. I can say, or many are found in academic medical centers, I can say that now that telehealth is so much more accessible, it's easier to find somebody. There are also several great self-paced programs online. So a great one that I like to recommend is called pain trainer. So people can look up pain trainer online and get access to this treatment.
该专业领域的毕业生输送渠道非常少。因此，随着人们对疼痛的生物-心理-社会模型越来越关注，希望这种情况能有所改变和转变。但这并不能改变当今医疗服务提供者匮乏的事实。所以，大多数提供者都在学术医疗中心。我可以肯定地说，或者说许多提供者都在学术医疗中心。现在远程医疗变得更加普及，寻找专业人士也变得更容易了。此外，网上还有几个很棒的自学课程。我喜欢推荐的一个非常好的课程叫“疼痛训练师”（Pain Trainer）。人们可以在网上搜索“疼痛训练师”并获得这种治疗。
There's another one out of Australia that people worldwide can access called the pain. Center, and that's out of McCory University in Sydney. So that's another sort of one of those self-paced programs that people can access and sort of work through on their own. So there are some great resources available online. So to wrap up, let me ask you, what are some of the new and most promising treatments that are on the horizon? I'm so excited about this new wave of treatments that is saying that we can reverse pain by addressing historical trauma or changing the way that the brain is processing pain. So we talked about emotional awareness and expression therapy. Another new treatment is called pain reprocessing therapy treatment. And the EAT has components of PRT
还有一个来自澳大利亚的课程，全球用户都可以访问，叫做“疼痛中心”（The Pain Center），由悉尼麦考瑞大学提供。这也是人们可以访问并自行学习的自学课程之一。所以网上有一些很棒的资源。最后，请允许我问您，目前有哪些新的、最有前景的治疗方法即将出现？我对这一波新的治疗方法感到非常兴奋，它们主张通过解决历史创伤或改变大脑处理疼痛的方式来逆转疼痛。我们谈到了情绪意识与表达疗法（EAET）。另一种新的治疗方法叫做疼痛再处理疗法（PRT），而EAET中包含了PRT的成分。
within it. So these treatments have a lot in common. And they're both based on the idea that in part, pain is part of an overactive threat response. So pain is your body's way of saying, something's wrong, right? Like stop what you're doing, look around, something's wrong. And so these treatments just, again, take a very different view of pain and sort of conceptualizing it as a brain generated response that's telling you that you're not safe. And so through a variety of different practices, you learn how to rewire that sequence. So you learn to tell yourself that you're safe and that your pain is, you know, either like kind of coming from your brain or being amplified by your brain, your brain, it's like, thank you, brain for trying to keep me safe, but I don't need that
这些治疗方法有很多共同点。它们都基于这样一个观点：疼痛在一定程度上是过度活跃的威胁反应的一部分。所以，疼痛是身体在告诉你“出问题了”，对吧？就像让你停下手中的事，环顾四周，看看哪里不对劲。因此，这些治疗方法再次以一种非常不同的视角看待疼痛，将其概念化为一种大脑产生的反应，告诉你你处于不安全的状态。通过各种不同的练习，你学会如何重新连接这一序列。你学会告诉自己你是安全的，你的疼痛要么来自大脑，要么被大脑放大了。你可以对大脑说：“谢谢你试图保护我，但我现在不需要这个。”
right now. My injury has healed. I know you're trying to keep me safe, but I got this. It's okay. And, you know, that's sort of a very sort of like simplified notion, but, you know, I think we can all relate to this idea that our bodies respond in a certain way when we're in a heightened state of distress. So these treatments are sort of conceptualizing pain for some people as one of those symptoms, which is positive because we can change the way that our body responds to stress. you know, this is a very new thing. It, again, has had really big effects in select types of chronic pain conditions, specifically those types of chronic pain conditions that can't be pinpointed in the body,
我的伤已经好了。我知道你在试图保护我，但我能应付。没关系。这是一种非常简化的概念，但我认为我们都能理解这种想法：当我们处于高度困扰状态时，我们的身体会以某种方式做出反应。因此，这些治疗方法将疼痛视为某些人的症状之一，这是积极的，因为我们可以改变身体对压力的反应方式。这确实是一个非常新的事物。它在某些类型的慢性疼痛中产生了非常显著的效果，特别是那些在身体上无法查明具体原因的慢性疼痛，
so they're not specifically related to a particular injury or disease process or something like that. And so, you know, we're learning how to translate those same findings to all types of pain conditions. So I'm really excited about that and, you know, excited to see where it goes from here. Well, Dr. Aaron, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think you've imparted a lot of useful information. Thank you. Thank you so much for having me. Kim, again, such an honor to speak to this audience.
也就是说，它们与特定的损伤、疾病过程或其他类似原因没有直接关系。因此，我们正在学习如何将这些发现转化为所有类型的疼痛状况。对此我感到非常兴奋，也很期待看到它未来的发展。好的，Aaron博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。我认为您分享了很多有用的信息。谢谢。非常感谢您的邀请。Kim，再次感谢，能与您的听众交流是我的荣幸。
And yeah, my favorite topic. And for our listeners, you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, YouTube, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you like what you've heard, please subscribe, leave us a review. And for those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.
是的，这是我最喜欢的话题。对于我们的听众，您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、YouTube、Spotify以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。对于那些想了解更多关于心理学和美国心理学会（APA）工作的人，您可以加入我们成为支持者。您不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology），以及购买我们的书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者您只是想了解更多科学知识，您可以访问以下网址成为支持者。
a. APA.org slash speaking. That's at. dat.apa.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcast, you can email us
apa.org/speaking。网址是 apa.org/speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件给我们
at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's
地址是 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是Kim Mills。在Ralphs享受更多省钱方式
like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如每个过道的低价商品。下载Ralphs应用程序，每周使用数字优惠券剪裁并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省1美元。在Ralphs，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省下一大笔钱。Ralphs SoCal，服务超过150年。储蓄可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请见网站。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。